hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich reagiere sehr gerne auf
inhalte von rtl
nun hat mir sehr sehr viele leute aus
meiner community der luke ruhe in die
kommentare geschrieben hätten könnten
musst unbedingt weil auch dommel dome
reagieren
ich wusste nicht wer das ist deswegen
habe ich mal googeln zum große meist
künstlerisch ausgestaltet kirche eines
bischofs mit ausgedehntem chor
wahrscheinlich solche auf eine kirche
reagieren dann hat google mehr als
zweites suchergebnis vorgeschlagen wird
um eine tv sendung präsentiert von daisy
dee sebastian radtke eva habe ich glaube
auch nicht dass ich darauf reagieren
soll dort alles ein biologie auf die
glorreiche idee gekommen das ganze
einfach mal bei youtube einzugeben
und da gibt es wirklich eine menge mit
donna wir widmen uns heute dem video
best of doppel da schauen wir uns wie
immer erst die kommentare an es tut mir
sehr wegen der werbung leid aber das hat
leider rtl geschalten also an der
steller rtl hat ihr das sehen sollte
dritte schaltet mich auch werbung bei
meinem video soll ich sonst meine frau
und die sieben kinder
der friseur ist weiblicher wie dumme
okay die einzige frage die ich mir
stelle ist wer hat die geschwängert
sommer wird schwanger in diesem video da
hat man doch gleich bock auf eine diät
ich esse gerade selber eine tüte chips
das problem ist dass ich glaube ich hier
nach auch bock auf süßigkeiten habe ich
kann da nicht mehr wirklich lachen ich
kann nur noch den kopf schütteln ich
glaube so wie es mir und euch als
zuschauer jetzt auch gehen von daher
starten wir jetzt mit der reaktion gegen
leverkusen liegt die 140 kilo schwere
dominik gregor i
er ist nämlich
ja alles voll mit süßigkeiten und da ist
die dominik gut mal nicht weitergeht
werden die kleine tochter leonie im
wohnzimmer spielt erfrischt sich die 23
jährige mit einer menge zuckerhaltiger
softdrinks süßigkeiten gehören bei der
stark übergewichtigen dominique zudem
grundnahrungsmittel ergänzt ich scheiß
auf wassereis auf obst früchte gemüse
brot süßigkeiten ist das a und o die
49-jährige mann eclipse ist die tante
von dominik die geliebten köstlichkeiten
versuchte minuten alle ethik zu
verstehen man zwar harmlos aber wollte
was herr horn
thome
ja
menschen ziemlich abstoßen lustig
gemacht
nach okay sind ja beide nicht so die
dünnsten zu kaufen ist ein schweinestall
helmut klein ist ja hier mit
abfallsäcken oder hasen oder anfang oder
nicht macht mensch
doch wer war nicht ein in der tasche
wird formal ist überall dreck gute man
den täter an kuba machen wir das ja
natürlich
die sind ja beide totale witzfiguren die
sind doch sage jetzt geht nicht gegen
die schauspieler oder so um gottes
willen das könne die nettesten personen
der welt sein aber die gespielten rollen
das sind ja mal kommt als mutter bist du
dazu verpflichtet du hast ein kleines
nettes mädchen und da du bist du
verantwortet und die kann ich in so ein
dreck stahl wohnen
[Musik]
die trommel achter einfach ich bin so
geschockt hiervon allem weiter das
kannst du was ist das denn hier
nichts ist jedoch dass kein scherz ist
gekommen ich hier rein
setz mich aufs sofa hier gibt es einen
schnellangriff ich werde hier erschossen
oder das sofa brief zusammen hat die der
tausende von tüten chips und süßigkeiten
das ding ist dass das video was wir
schauen ja ein best of doppel insgesamt
ist das heißt diese erste szene die wir
uns jetzt gerade angeschaut haben also
doch mit ihrer tante und dem kind im
wohnzimmer das war jetzt nur einen teil
des best ofs und es ist jetzt
abgeschlossen das heißt jetzt kommt nach
andere szene aus einer anderen folge am
meer doch dann fing marianne den friseur
dass ich diese diebe einblendungen von
rtl2 kann männer ohne hilfe um den
finger wickeln wenn sich die aus der
echten preis verdient nun verwandelt der
maestro dominiks bilderrahmen in ein
kleines kunstwerk doch marianne kann ist
einfach nicht ständig mischt sich die
49-jährige ein heller ganz kurz die
haare von der dame sehen aus als hätte
den schlüssel auf den kopf gesetzt
bekommen einmal darum herum geschnitten
dominik hat selbst überhaupt nichts mehr
zu sagen die frustrierte 23-jährige
stiebitz deswegen heimlich den keks ihre
sitznachbarin ich glaube mein schwein
pfeift aus dem letzten loch
immer wenn die doppel frustriertes haben
wir gelernt ist sie was aber dass sie
dann auch den keks vom nachbarn cloud
ist
wir schauen uns erwischt wurde erfahrung
geben
die kekse holen da klaut die dame von
der anderen frauen neben an den keks von
kaffee also das gibt hier so einen
frühstückskorb mit vier millionen keksen
während sie ihre haare immer schöner
werden lässt es sich die 140 kilo frau
richtig gut schmecken
der friseur leistet ganze arbeit und aus
der unscheinbar
der fries ganze arbeit und habe das höre
dass die data von rtl müsste man seine
ganz alles machen derweil aus der
unscheinbaren dominique ist ein schöner
schwan geworden
ja die huder geschminkt kriegsstraße
trevor meier
sie ist richtig echte style was muss ich
wirklich sagen die dumme sie besser als
vorher aus noch immer nicht in meinen
augen so dass ich sagen würde haye dumme
ich bereit für ein date mit lords aber
auf jeden fall besser als vorher
ja ich dachte er okay wenn sie jetzt
raus nimmt sie sich wahrscheinlich noch
ein keks mit lesen sie dir gott sei mit
dominique ist frustriert zum ersten mal
hat ihr ein arzt das gesagt was ihre
tante bereits seit jahren bringt ich die
23-jährige ist krankhaft dick und muss
dringend abnehmen
aus frust beginnt sie wieder zu essen
feiern
das ist ja so wie wenn der 1
sagt ja aufgrund des ganzen rauchen ist
es ihre lunge völlig amazon dann bist du
so genervt davon dass du dir erstmal ne
fluppe an machst wir sind übrigens
gerade wieder einer neuen szene in den
best of also nur zur info hat lediglich
gesagt dass du eine diät machen soll
unter ärztlicher aufsicht keiner hat
gesagt hast du rhin und psychiatrien
musst oder so psychiatrie wo lebt ihr
die rennen einfach nur ein bisschen zu
dick no shit das ist halt wirklich
nichts was heißt nichts schlimmes ist
halt schon gesundheitlich jetzt nicht so
gut aber wenn man ein bisschen mehr
kilos auf den rippen hat das ist doch
jetzt nicht schlimm
[Musik]
traurig ist dominieren pfannkuchen mit
schokoladencreme weiterfahren wird
bewusst dass sie krank es war endlich
ihren leiblichen vater finden muss
ok bommel weiß auch nicht wer ihr
leiblicher vater ist also sie hat gerade
zwei dinge also einmal das gewicht und
ihren vater was jetzt in den griff
kriegen muss jetzt gehen wir zu der
ärztin zurück und besprechen alles mit
hier und dann ist das heute der erste
tag in ein neues leben
respekt doch wirklich ich habe sehr
großen respekt vor leuten die sagen hey
komm ja aber wir wissen ja und ich hab
sie durchziehen wird aber ich selbst
habe das auch für das jahr 2009/10
vorgenommen dass ich nicht jede woche
zwanghaft fünf sechs mal ins
fitnessstudio gehen will sondern so zwei
drei mal einfach um fit zu bleiben
ernährung bisschen anpassen gestern
haben wir halt für bürger gemacht
nach dem intensiven gespräch suchen
marianne und dominik nochmals die ärztin
auf um ihre hilfe in anspruch zu nehmen
sinnvoll wäre auch wenn sie mal über
einige tage auf schreiben würden was sie
jeden tag essen aber wirklich alles also
inklusive der getränke der soße
nachdrucke da brauchte ja vier blöcke
pro tag sie werden nur abnehmen wenn sie
deutlich weniger kalorien zu sich nehmen
als sie verbrauchen das ist ja gerade
das ding viele leute die abnehmen wollen
die denken einfach nur herrlich es doch
schon weniger im trotzdem noch weiter zu
ihm ist und das ist so simpel wie man
abnimmt einfach weniger essen von dem
was man verbraucht sind hier
ernährungstipps mit luca dann nehmen sie
das erste mal für die nächsten paar tage
zur orientierung vor
gemüsesuppe rohkost teller mit käse mag
ich ja schon kosten wenn ich das allein
lese und man die richtige suchen schönes
ende die dame geht an mit der
gewichtsabnahme und findet ihren papa
dann demnächst ich dachte ich muss auf
jeden fall mal auf dauer reagieren
deswegen war ich ganz froh dass ich
dieses best of gefunden habe wenn es
euch gefallen hat was gerne mal einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video da schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare auf was ich
als nächstes reagieren soll
und
[Musik]